i think the secret to sustaining a
career is to always be changing and and
growing and learning as much as you can
as because different doors are open and
different doors closed show business a
lot of doors close and then the ones
that open sometimes those are the ones
you're supposed to go through because
you can't go through a closed door
unless you can in which case you're
really cool
be passionate about
whatever you're going to do if it's
something
serious to your life or it's something
that means something to you put
everything you believe in into it if
it's comedic
work really hard at making it funnier
just put your
spirit into it do that like you would do
you know
trying to hook up with somebody you
really wanted
kyle my favorite memory for my whole
career is talking to you right now
i've been thinking about you kyle i
don't know you
but i've just been thinking about you
and so this you asking me that
kind of made it clear to me this is the
best moment
of my entire career i'm talking to kyle
full house was a lovely family sitcom a
two-dimensional show made for 14 year
old girls and your family is your family
and that's you know full dimension your
whole life it's your family so i would
say the full house family taught me more